this is this is Yadkin and this is
probably the most in-depth piece of
content you'll see for me this year
Colorado [ __ ] got deep with me indie
rock hope you enjoy I think the world
like lacks optimism I think you know
everyone's like your energy your energy
I've come to realize it's just optimism
I'm just happy just positive that's what
it is just like whatever
chemicals are in my body they just allow
me to see the bright side like and I
just don't think I've realized how few
people have that like no very few people
have it as black and white hundred zero
like I just think everything's good but
like you know I'm dying no out of eight
billion people like what the breakdown
is like my gut is like six billion just
go directly into having more pessimism
and cynicism and negativity like 5149
minimally all the way down to very scary
places and I just don't think there's a
lot of 80 80 % optimism just environment
raised like it's just all that stuff
anyway what's up Jesse Gomez good to see
you coach John Castro great to see you
much love to all of you guys
and appreciate you so much I forced
myself to be optimistic every day does
not come naturally I get it Susan it
doesn't come naturally at a lot of
people I think I think that's like you
know if if I was able to say I'm lucky
about something forget about the
business results its lucky that that
optimism comes naturally to me like I'm
just optimistic like I just think that
so much works for me because I refuse to
accept the negative like I you know and
I don't think I hear what people say
it's you know it's an option or it's a
choice I agree with you Susan I don't
think it comes natural to everybody I
think we are just starting on the early
stages of a really looking at mental
health the brain meditation and I do
think alike that's like saying be
beautiful doesn't come natural to
everybody some of us you know yes I'm
just kidding
but like you know like I you know I I do
think that some of some things are are
matched with us early on and I'm I'm so
grateful I sit here in front of the
2,000 of you which is in itself is
ridiculous like I can turn something on
in three minutes and have 2,000 people
care enough to hear what I have to say I
say with here with ego and humility
gratitude and focus appreciation and
sense of responsibility all built around
really this optimistic foundation that
is the fuel that drives me to my hustle
and to my execution in the marketplace
and I thank you for your I thank you for
your I think you for your attention and
support and I and I recognize like you
know it's funny like
I wish people understood what I do with
my attention you know you know somebody
we just announced Vayner sports and
somebody wrote a cynical article saying
after watching the announcement of a new
sports it's obvious to me that Gary
Vaynerchuk loves to suck to hear himself
speak which is true but what I'd like to
say to that journalist unnamed you know
who writes headlines to make pennies in
banner ad advertising is my intent is a
fuckload better nourished partner what I
want to do with my attention is allow
the 2,000 of you to the tens of
thousands of you to take it I want to
hand you my optimism my happiness my my
view of the world my opportunities that
I see in the white space and I want to
give it to you for free and then I want
you to win and what I ask for in return
is the hope that I get an email or the
attention for you to say thank you I
have no interest in monetizing anybody
and and I think people are basic they
haven't figured me out
they have just not figured it out I get
off on people being grateful to me the
way I'm grateful to my mother and father
so
what you do with your attention is very
important and I implore all of you to
think about the people that you're
spending time and and allowing to have
your attention what is their intent have
you been able to reverse-engineer what
they want to happen are they looking to
bring you into a funnel into a master
class into an e-book into a course are
they looking for you to to invest in
their company are they looking for you
like what do they want what do they want
or like many people I'm not I'm not on
the island by myself are they just
grateful to get their craft out into the
world and see it live and in scale have
you found the people in your life that
have already won and are good that's
what I am that's why I'm so attracted to
my mom she's good doesn't need anything
I'm good I don't need anything from you
guys I just don't need anything from you
guys I don't want anything I want you to
listen and then how go have happiness
and success whether that's work-life
balance whether that's honing your
skiing skills whether that's building a
million-dollar business I don't care I
don't need you to be a hustler I don't
need you to be an entrepreneur I don't
need you to be a businessman I don't
need you to do anything I need you to
pay me back by going out and doing
something with what I'm giving you
paying back the the attention I'm taking
for you paying yourself back you know
giving me the feeling that I'm bringing
value to the world by actually doing
something about what I have to say
that's what I'm doing my attention what
are you doing with your attention anyway
back to you guys got into a little rant
mode they're off to work great job
answers I love that that's Buddhist
belief treat others as you would like to
treat your mother I believe in that
stuff whatever whatever whatever
religion or genre or practice or thesis
believes in doing the right thing and
doing right by others and then the
universe takes over and brings you value
I actually think it's not some karma
cosmic thing I think it's actually quite
practical would it not make sense to our
practical brains that if you're doing
something good for somebody else that
that puts you in a leveraged position
for something good to happen to you I'm
actually not very romantic or cosmic or
Spacey or Zena fide around providing
people value like I love karma I believe
in it because I believe Karma's [ __ ]
practical how about that because I
believe Karma's practical I believe that
if you do something good for somebody
else if you provide them value if you're
if you're taking their time and
providing them with good thoughts and
good themes and good strategies and good
outlooks and seeing white space I
believe that the people that started
snapchat it design agencies building
filters Oh broke out I believe that the
people that went out and built snapchat
design filter agencies that have been
making money over the last month because
they listen to me
yeah I believe that they'll they'll say
good things about me that will make more
people pay attention I believe that
they'll tell clients to work with me I
believe that they'll tell their sister
that's talented or their brother that
sounded to go work for Boehner or intern
there yes I do believe that doing the
right thing is practical I love it
when you're sick you got to get rest you
gotta get better right but low energy
doesn't come natural to me I've realized
what's going on here one life I realize
that I'm living like this is our only
at-bat and most of you are in people
[ __ ] walking around here like they're
coming back walking around here like
they're coming back you're not coming
back well listen I don't want to impose
my beliefs on others maybe you believe
to come back I believe you'd come back
to come back as a tree or a flower pot
or d-roc sneakers and that blows
compared to being a human
and so I'm acting that way I'm acting
that way
[Music]